In this course, you will learn how to create
a custom blog website without any code using
WordPress. I'm Beau with freeCodeCamp.org.
I've created a few popular WordPress courses,
and this one is specifically focused on creating
a blog. But you can use what you learn in this
video to create other types of websites, including
business websites, ecommerce sites, portfolios,
and more. You don't need any prior experience to
follow along, I'll teach you how to use a drag and
drop system that allows for easy and limitless
customization. So you can build the perfect
website for your needs. And the website will look
great on both desktop and mobile. Every website
needs a domain name and hosting. The domain is
what people type into a browser such as freeCodeCamp.org,
youtube.com, or wikipedia.org. Hosting
is where the files for your website are actually
stored. We'll be getting both the domain name and
hostinger.com. But you can still follow
along if you use a different hosting provider,
just use the timestamps in the description to skip
to what you want to learn. Hosting are provided
a grant that made this course possible. But I
had already used hosting or personally in the past
and had a good experience hosting or is optimized
for WordPress sites and has a 99.9%. uptime
guarantee. They also give you a free domain and
free SSL. So we can just go here, get click Get
Started. And then you can decide whether you're
going to create a brand new website or transfer an
existing website. Well, we're creating a brand new
website. And you can you don't have to go through
all this. But we are doing a WordPress here.
And I'm just going to go through here and it'll
tell you what kind of package we want to do. So
we can just skip this for now, it because this is
actually an upgrade, but we don't want to upgrade.
So I'll just go to skip here. And then it's going
to recommend the Premium shared hosting plan. So
you can actually go and just select your plan
manually. But this will help you figure out the
exact plan you want. You can see right here, you
can actually host 100 different websites on this
plan, and you get a good amount of storage and
you get unlimited bandwidth. So that's pretty
good. You includes a free domain, and an SSL
will make it so you have a secure website. So
this is a good option. So I'm just going to select
that. And then it's going to show where you can
actually upgrade if you want or you can choose
a different amount of months. And you can see,
depending on how many months you buy, the time
is is how much it's going to renew for. So you
can see this one renews at 6.99, 7.99, 8.99 or 11.99 a
month. So just pick whatever one you think is
going to work best for you. If you're just testing
it out, you could just do a one month plan. Or if
you know you're going to have a website long term,
you can do one of these other plans. And then
after you get all this set up, you can go through
just to create the account, and you can select
your payment, and then you can submit it. So
I'm not actually going to type in everything.
But it's pretty straightforward if you're going
to create your own account for the first time.
So after you get logged in, and possibly as
part of creating your account, you're going
to want to get your domain. So if you're done
creating your account and you haven't gotten
a domain through that process yet, we can just
click on claim domain right in the main menu.
Now here is your you're going to have to have
a domain name that's never been used before. It
could take you a few tries to find one that's not
already taken. But I'm gonna go with B e a u with
the dashes that's my name oh, but my name doesn't
have dashes but ODOT now let's check availability.
And I already tested this so I knew I
knew it work and I will claim domain.
Okay, now he's had to set up
this domain registration details
and we'll just finish filling this out.
Okay, the domain is registered. Okay,
now add the website to the hosting plan.
And I already had this hosting plan registered
for this other website. So select that one
website connected successfully. Now we'll show
you how to set up an email account on your domain
through hosting her. So I'm under hosting her
home tab. After I'm logged in, and I'm going to
just click emails. And now I'm going to the so I
already set up this from before but now I'm gonna
set the email on the domain we just created. So
I'm just gonna click there and then create email
account and then I'm just going to I'm typing it
automatically filled in something, but I can type
in anything I want. So I'm going to put Bo and
then I'm just going to type in a password here.
And then create. Okay, so now people can email
me at Beau at B dash E dash a dash u.net. And
then I can access the email by still being
on this email tab here and going to webmail.
And then I'll just sign in here. And there
are no messages. But I can always compose a
new message here. And then I'll receive
messages if someone sends me a message.
And now let's go over how to set up SSL for the
website. So I'm going to go to the SSL tab on
this hosting or dashboard. And SSL is important,
it makes sure all data coming and going from your
website is secure. And nobody's going to be able
to, there won't be any hackers or anybody that
can see what's going on with the website. If
someone submits information, it will be secure,
nobody will be able to see what that information
is. So I'm just going to click the Install SSL
button. And then I'm going to select the website
and just click Install SSL. And the great thing is
that it's it's free, it's completely included
within hosting or within the plan. And now I
should have SSL but I'm gonna have to actually
do this drop down menu to go to the boat.net
to see the one that we just added. And you can see
it's installing it says it may take up to an hour.
But then after that, we can go to the website
instead of going to http colon slash slash vote
on that it will be HTTP s colon slash slash vote
on net because it has SSL. It's the S stands for
secure. I'll go back to the dashboard. Now I want
to get WordPress installed on the website. Many
different website hosting services allow you to
easily install WordPress on the website. So the
exact method could be different if you're not
using hosting or, but it should be relatively
similar. So I'm just going to scroll down on
this page here. And I'm going to click WordPress.
And then I'm going to install WordPress. And I'll
fill this out to finish setting up. So let's call
it my website for now. And anything here can be
changed later. And then I'll put in the password.
And then I'll just use these default
settings here and click Install.
We're on the hosting or dashboard. We want
to go to the WordPress dashboard. So we can
start creating our WordPress website. So just
click on Edit website. If you're using something
besides say the WordPress there'll be something
similar to get into the WordPress dashboard.
Another way you can always access your WordPress
dashboard. If you look in the URL bar here,
we have the URL name. And then it's slash WP dash
admin. You can always go to slash WP dash admin to
get to your WordPress dashboard. Okay, it zoomed
in a little bit on this, and we're just gonna look
at some of the things on the menu over here. These
are all things that are important when creating a
WordPress page. We have our posts when we're going
to create a new post, but you're likely going to
be creating a new page, like the about us page
contact page and stuff like that. And you can also
change your appearance. And there's just a bunch
of other sections here, many of which we'll be
going over in more detail later in this tutorial.
But first of all, let's go over to users. And you
just want to make sure that you have a a password,
we just want to make sure that the password is
the password we chose. Now, depending on how you
installed WordPress, you may not have created a
password. And depending on what hosting provider
you use, and use meant when it may maybe verify
that you're not going to have a default password.
So I'm just going to type in a password here.
And then I'm going to do update profile. Okay,
now we're going to go to the plugins tab.
Before we deal with the plugins, let's
just get rid of some of these tabs.
I'm going to click x here, we don't
need this. I guess they're not tabs,
they're just information boxes. And to get rid of
this one we're going to go through and actually
delete some of the extra plugins here we don't
a lot of these plugins we don't actually need
so I've selected all the extra plugins and I
don't need this one either. And I'm going to go to
first I'll do deactivate and then I have to
select them again, and I'm gonna go to Delete
And don't worry if you accidentally
delete a plugin that you actually need,
because it's really easy to reinstall
them. So I'm gonna go to Delete.
Okay, and now we've deleted all the plugins we
don't need. And you can see we no longer have the
extra information box up here that was associated
with a particular plugin. Now, no matter what type
of website you're trying to make, you're probably
going to want to install a theme. And that's what
we're going to do themes make it way easier to
create the website that you want to create. And
a lot of themes come with various templates. So
one theme can have multiple templates. And each
template can be for a different types of type of
website. Now, what you're going to want to do is
go to add new, and there's tons of different types
of different themes that you can install. One of
the most popular ones is Astra, so just go up here
and search for Astra and Astra comes with a lot of
different templates you can use. So it's basically
one theme that has one way of kind of modifying
and editing it. But there's all these templates
for different types of websites, including blogs,
we're creating a tech blog. And let me show you
how we can get that set up with Astra, pretty much
everything I'm going to teach you will work with
will apply to any theme that you choose. So if you
choose a different theme, it's still you're still
going to be able to do most of the things that I'm
showing you. So I'm going to go with Astra and
I already have it installed, so you're going to
have to install it, and then you're going to
have to activate it, I'm just going to click
Activate here. And then once it's activated,
we can just go to get started. But you can see
right here has come to dozens of reviews, thorough
templates. So that's what we're going to be using.
So I'll click Get Started. And then we can scroll
down, we don't need to watch the video here,
build your website now. And then it's going to
say select your page builder. A page builder is
just something that you can use to create your
page to modify it and to make changes on it. So
block editor, this is the default editor that
comes with WordPress. And Elementor and beaver
builder are third party editors, but they're both
very popular. And if we click, if we choose one of
these, we can still also use this one because it's
still built into WordPress. So I'm gonna go with
Elementor. That's one of the most popular ones.
And that's going to make it even easier to editor
website and making it make it look exactly how we
want it to look. And so pretty much all of these
themes, all these templates off, they all
often have free versions and paid versions,
they're trying to make some money, so so they're
gonna give you the free version to get to you to
install it. But then you may see a paid version
that you want to upgrade. But in this course,
we're only using free versions. And you can
do quite a bit with free versions. So these
are all these templates that you can choose
from. And you can see if it says premium,
that's obviously one of the paid ones. But there's
quite a few of the free versions. So you can see,
these are all different ones. And what you want
to do is find something that looks close to what
you want, or somewhat similar. And you can
do a considerable amount of customizing. So
it doesn't have to look exactly like what you
want. But find one that's kind of the closest,
and then you can go through and basically
customize every single part of it. So it fits it
perfectly fits what you're trying to do with your
website. Since we're going to go with a distance
recruiting a tech blog, I'm going to use this
creative blog. So I'm gonna just click on here,
and then we can upload a logo, but it look
good, it says don't have a logo, no problem,
you can upload it later. So that's true for in
this initial customization that we're going to do
be doing everything you can do later. So you don't
have to do it. Now you can always change things,
anything that you do, you can always change back.
So I'll skip and continue. And then we can change
the color. So see, whenever we click that we
can see different things on the page. Turn,
if we go down here, we can see more, more things
changing colors. You can see if we go down here,
see, different things are going to change color.
So I kind of like this green one. So we're
gonna go with that one. And then we can choose
what font we want. And if we go back up here,
we can kind of see the heading, I'm gonna go with
this one, I kind of like the different small,
like the curve saris that are on the
letters there. So we're gonna continue
and then we can talk a little bit about yourself,
but I don't want to I'm not going to tell anything
about myself. And so we can choose a way I
meant to not agree to receive anything. And
so you can basically leave all these checked.
I'm not going to share sensitive data but We'll
import all these things that are going to help
the theme work. So submit and build my website.
Okay, now we just have to wait. And you can see it
says installing require theme plugins and forms.
So we could install the themes and the forums,
individual individually. But this is we're
just going to do it all for us. So to do all the
ones that we need to, to make our template work,
congratulations, our website is ready.
So I'm gonna go to view your website.
And now we can see what the website looks like.
This is basically the default website, we see that
we have the title of the logo up here. And there's
these this menu here, we can do a search, and we
can subscribe. And so if we scroll down here, we
can see we can subscribe to a newsletter. There's
basically an ad here, which is just a sample ad,
which we're definitely going to remove. And so
we have different categories of the articles that
are that are on this website, and some podcasts.
Now these aren't any won't play anything, because
this is just kind of an example of what it could
look like if you have podcasts. And then we have
this bottom menu here and some social links, and
you can install or subscribed on here. And then
if we go here, these are all different categories
of articles, so articles about film articles
about advertising, articles about photography.
So if I scroll down, we see that's one article.
And then here's another article. So each article
has a picture headline. And I can click into
that. And then we can read the full article.
And this is just dummy text, lorem ipsum, it's not
going to so this is just like an example of what
an article would look like. And then there's
related posts, and you can leave a comment.
So we're going to focus on building a blog.
But like I said, everything that we're doing
will apply to pretty much any type of website
you're creating. So if you want to create a
Sophina, if you want to create a business page,
or a portfolio page, or any type of website,
you'll be able to follow along and apply a lot
of these same concepts to any type of website.
So if I go to full screen mode, we can see that
when we're on the website, it just says my website
right here, well, we want to say something
different. So that's the first thing we're
going to customize. We're going to see how to
customize a bunch of stuff. But the first thing
is just going to be the title up here. Oh yeah, I
don't need this tab open. This is the tab where it
installed everything. So I'll close that. So let
me go back to WordPress. And we'll fullscreen that
again, I'll go to settings, general settings.
And then here is where we can change the site
title and tagline. And whenever you install
templates, every once in a while it's going to
pop up different things like this, we can just
close that. So I'm gonna call this the site
title. This is a tech blog. So we're gonna
call it tech tuba. And then for the tag line
will say all the best tech news, I could just
select it because I had already typed that in
earlier. So then you can also change all these
other things. You never want to change the URL,
but you can change the administration
email, you can change the site language,
timezone date format. So these are all things
you can customize. I'll just click save changes,
we're just going to change the title.
And so now if I open up the website
and then we can see right here, tech
tuba, all the best tech news. Okay,
before we start customizing this further, I'm
gonna go back over to WordPress. And I'm gonna
go over to the plugins. So I talked to you about
how some plugins were installed, automatically.
You can see these blue rows here are the ones that
are just installed with Elementor. That's to help
us edit the page and a more easily an easy way
starter templates that gives us access to all the
different starter sites. And we chose we chose one
from their web forms, this is going to make it so
we can easily get our contact form to work. Okay,
so let's go back to our page. So we already looked
at all these different things. So now we're going
to start actually customizing it. So there's a few
different ways you can start customizing. So we're
first going to click on Customize right here.
First of all, you can see it says more options
available and Astra pro so like I said, there's
a few different things where they try to upsell
you. But we don't need any of those extra options,
you get quite a bit of options just in the free
version. So you can change the theme, which we're
not going to do. But if we go to global and we
go to colors, this is where we can change the
colors we did when we were setting up the theme
we chose some colors, but if you want to make some
changes, you can do it here. Like for instance
I can for global one, I can change to red,
and you can see right here that button change to
red. And then if you ever say oh Don't want that.
And instead of clicking publish publish is going
to save what you just chose, I can just hit X,
and then it's going to say the changes will be
lost. So I'm going to make those changes last. And
now it goes back to green. Now I'm gonna go back
to customize, this will go back over to there.
And to global, we can also change the typography.
So this will change what the different what kind
of fonts we're using. And then you can change
the fonts for different elements on the page,
like different headings, and there's just
a bunch of different things that we can
change. So we can change the layout, we can
change, what buttons are going to look like,
like it can make it, so it's the buttons
that are going to be kind of white like that,
I can change some padding border width of the
buttons, like, like, maybe I want to have 10
for the border with. So you can see these buttons
just got a lot bigger, because the width of around
the border got bigger. But I'm gonna change
that back to zero. And then I'll go back here.
We can also change the header, breadcrumb blog,
we're gonna be going through some of these later.
But one thing I want to focus on right now is the
site identity. This is where you can actually add
a, an icon that's going to appear in the URL bar.
And then you can also add a logo. So right now
there's the this logo, the creative room ad. And
you can see we have the normal logo and the retina
logo. The difference is the type of screen. So
retina screens are generally generally screens
that have more pixels per inch, so you need a
higher resolution logo. Now you can use the same
logo for both. But also you have the option to
put a higher resolution logo for the retina logo.
And you can see while we're on this page, you
can see this other menu has appeared down here.
And it's basically showing all the different the
different pieces of content that are above the
main content. So we have this is the main content
here. But this is showing at the very top we have
the site title and logo which are right here.
And then this line right here is this line,
where we have the primary menu, which it does, it
is putting the menu down to the second line here,
which will I'll show you how to fix that later.
And then we also have the search in the button.
That's what we have right there. And then there's
there's nothing in this third, we can add. So if
we wanted to add something in there, like an
additional menu or something that was at the
top of every page, we could, but right now let's
do the logo. Now there's a lot of websites out
there that can help you create a logo for free.
And then there's different websites out there
where you can hire people to create logos, such
as Fiverr. But I just went ahead and created a
logo myself. So I'm going to change the logo. And
then I can either drop files or select the file.
So I'm just going to drop this file here. And we
just uploaded the logo. And then for the alt text.
Now the alt text is helpful for Well, for one,
if people can't see the image, then they can,
or they're able to read the alt text. And
also if the image doesn't load correctly,
it will it will be able to show the alt text
so it's good to have an alt texts for all your
images. So I'll do tech tubuh logo, and then
I will select OK. Oh, now I can I can crop it,
I'm going to crop it. So it just uses the entire
image and then click crop image. Or I guess it
could have clicked skip cropping since I'm not
cropping. And so I'm going to have to upload
it in two spots. I'm gonna have to upload it
here. And then I'm just going to upload the
same one for the retina logo. So there and choose
Image. Okay, so now it shows tech two, but now
it's a little bigger than I was wanting it to
be. So let's see how we can change the size of
the logo. So to change the size of the logo, I
can go down here, and then we can set the logo
width. We can also set a few different things
like the site title and the tagline by line go
to the width. And I'm going to just set a specific
width. So before if you don't have anything here,
it's just going to basically be the default.
So if I just delete that, or if I like no yes,
put zero if you put zero it will put the default
size but I am going to make it smaller. So I'm
going to set a specific size now out this. So some
of the design decisions I'm creating I'm doing
may not look the best, but you can kind of keep
tweaking things until things look exactly how you
want it to look. So I've already noticed that we
have the blue here, so it'd be kind of nice, maybe
it's a buttons, what were the same shade of blue,
which we can do already, so yet how to change
that color. For now, though, we'll just we'll
just move on to the next part of our website.
So now I'm going to go back. And for now I'm
going to, I'm not going to do anything more,
we're gonna actually come back to some of these
later, if you want to go through and just check
them out yourself, you can't wait, we're gonna
come back to some of these later. So right now,
I'm just going to click the Publish button. And
then now that's published, I can hit the X here.
Okay, and, you know, now that I'm seeing it, yeah,
I am gonna go and change the color. So it matches
that the logo that we just got. So we'll go
back to customize. And then global colors,
I'll just change these greens, the blues, so I'm
gonna change that this too. And if I can basically
get something kind of close to what's in the
image in the logo that we developed. So let's do
that's a good color for that line. And then
here, we're going to do a darker blue for that.
Okay, so you can see we have dark blue, and light
blue. Okay, looks good. And so we'll publish that.
Okay, so now I'm gonna go and
continue to make some changes here.
So let's start customizing this page will first
work on customizing this homepage. And then we'll
look about how to customize the other sections
of the page, including the blog entries. First,
we're going to go to edit with Elementor. If we
go to Edit page, we'll use the WordPress built
in editor. But Elementor makes some things
a little easier when you're editing. So I'm
gonna click edit with Elementor. And then we got
this open. And you can see we have the Elementor
side panel. And then we have the navigator over
here, I'm going to pull this to the side and
make the navigator go all the way to the side.
And we can still kind of scroll back and forth
to see the whole page. And the cool thing about
the Navigator. I'll talk about that before I go
to this menu over here, the navigator is going to
show all the elements in the page. So we have if
we just open these drop down menus, we have
this heading, which is this one right here,
the image box, which is right here, and then we
have a button, we get the see when we click on it,
it will kind of highlight it. So that image
is this image down here. And then we have
another column, which is this image right here. So
basically, in this section, there are two columns,
the left column and the right column. And then we
can scroll down here. And actually, if I zoom out
a little bit here, we'll be able to see a little
more on the page at once. So we come down and look
at the next section. And the next section just has
one column, it has this image box. And then it has
this form. And then we have the final section,
which just has one column, which has image,
which is this ad here, the heading but so so I'm
not gonna go through the rest of them. But you can
kind of see, you can see how it can make it easier
to select one specific part of your page. And you
can see as we move our mouse around it, we
can each element or each section on the page
will have this little edit button. So what I'm
gonna do for now is just close this navigator,
we're not going to use a navigator, and then
close it. So it makes things easier to see on
the page. So let's start doing some editing to
the page. So I'm going to click right into here,
I can click if I click this edit button, it will
bring up our Edit section over here. And you can
see this just happens to be an image box and the
image. So you can have a text box or an image box.
So this image box just happens to not have an
image with it. But it does have a title and a
description. So I can actually change that I can
actually change it right on the page like this
best tech news, or I can I can
change it right over here. I can say
your one stop page for all the latest tech
news. And so we can go through and basically
click each element and make some changes. So this
read article will let me go to this read article
button. So If we go to the button, we can, we
can change the text of the button, I can say,
go to stories. So it will go to specific
stories, we can change that the type of button,
which is this is just going to basically be
different colors of the buttons, you can see.
Well, let's go back to the default. But
specifically, I'm going to look at the
link right now, this button doesn't actually do
anything. If you have a link, and it just has the
this pound sign or hash mark hash tag here, that
just means it's an empty link. It's a link that
doesn't go anywhere, but we want to go somewhere.
So what I'm going to do is make it go to the film
page. And so if I hover over the film page, you
can see the bottom left hand corner of the screen,
you can see the URL for the film page.
And we're going to make it say that URL,
or I can just go to copy link address, and then
I can just put the link right here. So now when
we click the Go to stories page, it will go
directly to this category. And we can also do
other things like we can change the alignment of
the button, we can change the size of the button,
we can change the spacing. And then you can
also open up these link options. And you can
choose is this button going to open up this link
and open up into a new window, there's a bunch
of up options you can do for a button. Now let's
go over here, I'm going to go over to this image
right here. And I'm going to change this image.
So if I go to choose image. Now for some reason,
these tabs aren't showing this. So if I hover you
can see here's where you upload a file, or here
it says free images, I'm not quite sure hopefully
on your, you're just not being hidden like that.
But if I got a free images, we can see this is
powered by Pixabay. Now Pixabay is just a way is
a is a website where you can get free royalty free
images. So I'm going to search for technology. And
then I'm actually going to change the orientation
to do a vertical orientation, because I think
that will work better in that spot. I guess
it's not having any for vertical orientation.
Okay, so now if I just search for Tech,
we can get this vertical orientation.
And I like this one, because it has a lot of
technology in it. It's really about broadcasting.
Now you can go through and find the images
in another place and upload it. But for now,
I'm just gonna throw in this image right here.
And insert media. Okay, so now we have this,
this image that we put into our website. And we
can also change other things like right here,
this is also an image right here, I'm gonna
keep it here, we'll just go down and see
that subscribe to our newsletter. And I can go
through and change this and say, you will get
the best articles to your inbox. And then you can
see where you can put in your email address and
subscribe. And later, we'll get we'll also show
you how to set this up so it works even better. So
we're going to go we're going to show how to use
this subscribe form and the contact form. So I'll
show you that later. Now we don't want to have
ads on our page. So I'm going to show you how to
just remove this section completely. So what I'm
going to do to delete the section, I could click
click this X button, but that's going to click
delete this whole section, including the podcast,
the categories, and this ad here. So to delete
just this ADD, basically I'm gonna select,
I'm gonna right click, and I'm gonna go to delete,
and just deletes that section. So when we I want
to keep the popular category section, but this
is just a tech blog, we don't have podcasts. So
I'm gonna delete this podcast section also. So I'm
going to right click, go to Delete. And then here,
I can actually just hit this X button, it's
going to delete that whole section. So we have
the four different categories. So let's update our
categories. These are the categories we're going
to have, we're going to have a category called
news. We're gonna have a category called reviews.
And then we're going to have a category called
gaming. And then we're going to have a category
called Software. Okay, now we can if we wanted to,
we can actually right click and delete just one
of these buttons or one of these categories
or we could even add new code categories,
if we want to add a new one, I could actually
right click on this and go to duplicate. And
so now there's a five here instead of four, but
I'm gonna just delete that because we only want
the four here. And then if I can delete another
one to go to three. So now we have these, these
four different categories. And let's just choose
new images. So for news, I'm going to go to Edit,
I did a right click Edit Column. In the in
style, this is where I can change the image.
So I'm going to click Choose Image, I'm just going
to basically choose some images that are already
in there to make that faster for reviews, I've
got to choose image, and we'll use this image.
And then for reviews, I got to edit column again
style, then I'll use this for the reviews. And
then for gaming, I am going to go to style.
And then we could go to the free images and
select one. But to make it quick, I'm just
going to select an image that's already on
here. So this person is not quite playing game,
but we're just going to use that one. And then
I'll just choose another one really quick for
software. And we'll do that one. So now we've kind
of we've learned how to edit this. But let's see
how we can add a new column. So what if we want
something after the categories what if we want
something else? Well, there's a few different ways
to do it. If we want to in between, we can press
this plus button, but I'm but if we want this at
the end, it's already it's always going to show
you so always going to have one at the end that
you can add. So I can click this. And then we can
select the structure, you can see these there's
different column layouts we can choose. And so
I'll click that. So now we're going to have,
we can see right here, so we have the small column
here in the larger column here, by click here.
Now it's going to show us all these different
elements we can add. So we may want to have a
heading. So I can drag this heading here. And then
we can edit the Kaeding, we can change the size,
we can change the style, we can also go back to
the elements here, then I can add some text right
underneath here. So we can have heading here.
And it's also cool how easy it is to add a video,
we can click the plus button here, if you don't
already have the elements section up here. And I
can bring in a video. And once you bring in the
video, then we can just put in a specific URL.
So I'm just gonna paste in the URL here. And so
this is a good tech related video how to build a
Hackintosh. And you can even specify the start
time in time whether you want to autoplay No,
because everyone hates auto playing. And then
there's a bunch of other options that you can,
you can choose player controls, if you want,
we'll turn off the controls. So there's a bunch
of things you can do, we want to turn on privacy
mode, that's something you probably want to do,
because then it's not going to attract people.
And so then when you go to your website,
people can have this video here. So there's a
bunch of different things you can, you can edit,
you can kind of go around and change different
things. But let's go over to I want to show you
how to update these blog sections or the article
sections. Were later we're going to talk about how
to update all this stuff down here. So we have
different choices. We have film, advertising,
photography, digital, and we got rid of podcasts.
So let's make it so this is all updated. If we
click here, you'll notice that if see if I move
my mouse around, you can see wherever my mouse is,
there's a blue box around, but there's no blue box
around over here. Because this menu, we have to
edit in a separate spot of, of WordPress, we don't
we don't edit this menu through Elementor. So,
first of all, let's take a note of the things
news reviews gaming software, that's what we're
going to change this menu to. And what I'm going
to do is click Update to save all the changes
we had from before. Now we're gonna go out of
Elementor I'm gonna click this hamburger menu
and then I'm just gonna go to View Page. Okay, so
we can see the page with all the updates we made.
You can see this gets a little, maybe too long,
we can go up. So that's something we can actually
edit. So this image doesn't go down so far.
But we can see it has these changes. We've have
this whole new section here. So let's see how to
update that menu. We're gonna have to go back into
the WordPress dashboard. So I'm gonna hover over
Appearance, and then I am going to go to menus.
And here is where I'm going to update that
top menu. You can see all these different
options. So we're not going to have
podcast, so I'm just going to click this
and go to the drop down menu and then remove
and then I'm also going to get rid of this one
Because we really only want four items, and
then now we have to rename. So to rename these,
we're actually going to change the categories.
So first of all, I'm going to save that,
and it says menu has been updated. And
then let's change the category names.
So it changed the category names, we'll go to
posts. So these are all default posts that are
just kind of brought in based on our theme.
And then we go to categories. So here's all
the categories, and this is the one we deleted.
So I'm gonna delete that one digital. And now
I'm gonna change the name of these other four.
So advertising, I'm gonna change to news. And
then the slug, this is what's going to be in the
URL I select to update it. So it will go into the
URL, I'll show you how to do that later. So
this is what the URL is going to look like.
And then we'll update that, go to categories. And
then we can go to the next one, which will be the
design one. Oh, and we can do with a quick edit
to make it a little quicker. And we'll do reviews,
reviews. And then the film,
this is going to be gaming
and then software. So most types of blogs, you're
going to have different categories. And so this
is how you update them. So if we go back to our
our website, and I'm just going to refresh here,
we can see it automatically updated these here.
So review reviews, gaming, new software. So let's
see how we can put that in a different order.
So we want those to be in the same order as
our categories down here. So what I'm doing is,
basically, I have these two tabs over here. So
I'm using shortcut keys to switch between them. So
I'm going to go back over here. And then I can go
back to Appearance and Menus. And now I can move
these around. So the first thing is going to be
news reviews, gaming software. And after moving
around, I can save that. And if I go back over
here and refresh, news reviews gaming software.
So now yeah, now we have the different categories.
So these different articles are in these
categories. These are all the sample articles.
So now that we learn how to make different blog
post categories, let's see how to customize what
these these pages look like. So this page is the
page that's going to show a little bit of each
article. And then when you click into the article,
that's where it's going to show the full article.
So there's two different things that we need to
customize, you can see that there's no edit with
Elementor. Because when we're on editing this
page, we have to do it a little differently. So
I'm gonna click customize, and then go to blog.
And so there's two things here, the blog archive,
which is basically this page here. And then we
also have the single post, which is when you
click into the posts, so the blog archive, I can
change what this is going to look like. So like
for instance, if I click here, now, it's going
to basically make it a little smaller, and put
the title here. So we can kind of just experiment
with clicking some of these different layouts.
So here before, we didn't have a sidebar,
but here we have a sidebar, where we can,
if we want a sidebar with some extra information,
we can add that. So we have a search here
where we can search for blog posts, that are
Recent Posts, Recent Comments, the archives,
and I kind of like that I want people to
be let's see, when they go to this page,
the I want them to be able to search for things.
And I want them to be able to look see the recent
posts. And we can also switch what side of the
side that's on. So if we keep scrolling down here,
we can do different things like we can turn on
or off the featured image. So we want the image
to show up. Do we want the title and metadata to
show up? Do we want the my comments so right now,
none of these have comments. But if I take this
off, you can even leave a comment. And then we
can turn on or off the category. So right now see
it says the keywords the comments, the category
and the author. So those are the things we can
turn off or on we can turn on the publish date.
And so there's just a bunch of things you can do
to change what your blog is going to look like.
And you can even change the CIO CEO says recent
Post, if I click this little edit button here,
it's going to first of all, I'm just gonna click
got it, and that's gonna come into here. And now
I can change what this is going to look
like. So instead of saying recent posts,
I can say maybe recent articles. Now it's gonna
say recent articles. And then I can even, maybe,
if I highlight that I can make it bold. I
guess that's not doing anything, but I can
make it italic, italic. And there's all sorts of
things you can change. And that can change this
stuff here, like maybe I don't want the recent
comments. So let's say if I, if I don't want this,
I can, if I don't want the recent comments, I
can click on these three little blocks here,
these three little dots. And I can say remove
group. And what if I want the archives above,
I can click here and I can move the archives
above, or it can with archives below. And you
can just play around with this and get it
to look exactly how you want it to look.
So I'm now I'm going to go into the
actual blog post. So if I go into here,
and now now we want to edit this blog post, so I'm
going to blog and single post. So now there's a
lot of other things we can do once we in here, do
we want to use the box layout, full width layout,
so you can kind of try different things
about what exact what the layout you want,
for each individual blog post, you can change
the custom with the content wet. And then you
can check check whether it's going to show the
featured image basically all the same information
before you can put on here. And we can change
how many related posts for any space right now
there's only one But we can say how many related
posts, we want to show up right here. Okay,
now I'm going to save the changes that
I made to that. So I'll hit publish.
So now that we know how to modify this and change
what the blog looks like, how do you actually add
new blog entries? Well, it's simple. So I'm
going to hit X here. And I'm going to go back
into WordPress. So there's a few ways to add a new
post, I can either hover in the post and go to add
new, or I can hover over this new at the top, go
to post, there's a bunch of things you can add.
So I'll go to new post. And I will create a new
article, website offers free developer curriculum.
So I'm just gonna start typing in here.
You can learn to code for free at Free
Code camp.org. It's a great website.
And then I can add something else. So I can click
this plus button here. And I can add a gallery,
which is makes it so you can see multiple
images and switch between them, or a quote,
or an image, I'll go to image. And I'll go to
the media library. And we'll just add these,
this milk here. So we have this text. And then
we have this image here. And then I can even
change the size. So if I go to the side, it's
gonna give us some more options. So image size,
I'm gonna do a medium image. And then if we
go to advanced, you can add title attributes,
you can make a link here, additional CSS. But
what I'm also want to do is make sure for this
post I'm you can add a bunch of other things in
in your blog posts. But what I'm going to do is
make sure I assign it to a specific category,
this is going to be in the news category. I also
want to make sure I add a featured image. This
is the image that will appear at the very top
of the article. So the featured image is not an
image from the article, you have to add a another
image. So I'm going to click show featured
image. And I'm going to go to upload files.
And that's gonna drag a file in here.
And again, I am going to add an alt text
Free Code Camp website. And then
I'll set it as the featured image,
which is just a screenshot of
the Free Code Camp website.
And there's a few other things you can do. Like
we can change the excerpt. This is optional,
but if you want to basically like a summary of
the article that's going to appear on the when
it's showing the list of all articles, this
would be the excerpt that's going to show
up and you can also set tags So, tags will
be different than categories. And it's just
another way to chain. It's just another way to
sort your articles. So I could say, websites.
And then it says separate with the comments or
the enter keys. So what we can now search. Now,
we can now add this tag to the article. Okay,
now I can click Publish to publish the article.
And then I can even click View Post right here.
So here's the Post website offers free developer
curriculum. And we can see this is the main image.
And here's the article. And then we even have some
related posts. And if I click on the news page, so
here's one of the posts. Here's the other posts.
So we have three different posts, including the
Free Code Camp post. And you can basically do
that for basically whatever category you add, is
the category it's going to show up on here. Okay,
that's basically all there is to it to adding blog
entries, and customizing blog entries. Let's look
at how to customize the about page and the contact
page. So the way you customize this, about page is
going to be just like we did that the homepage. So
we're going to edit with Elementor. And now we can
go through and in update things on here, like this
thing right here, we probably don't even though
that's all right click, and then I will delete.
And now we can go through and update this text.
We are the most trusted news source. And you
can go through and just update this as much as
you want. And we can delete a section like
this, this looks like it's supposed to be
like an ad or something, well, I want to change
that name. As we don't want to use an ad image,
I'll just change it to this one right here. So
now you can go through. And basically you can
change as much as you want see, any way you click
it, you can just go through and start editing.
So it's pretty straightforward. It's kind of,
so I'm not going to go through and change all
these things. But when we go to the contact
page, it's going to be a little different.
actually refresh the page, I didn't click
update. So it didn't save this. That's okay,
you know how to do it. So we're gonna just look
at how to update the Contact page, because that's
gonna be a little different. But sometimes when
you're in Elementor, to get to another page,
you're first going to have to go out of Elementor.
And then you can go back into it. So I'm just
going to go to View page, go into contact, and
then we'll go to edit with Elementor. Again,
and so you can a lot this stuff, you can edit
just like you did before, like for this company
information, set up having an address, I'm
going to get rid of that. And I'm going to say,
bow at Free Code camp.org. So I'm just going to
put an email address. And then I can actually
make this a clickable email address, I'll to, to
make to make an email address that you can click
on and it opens your default editor, you can type
in a link just like this, you mail to and then put
a colon and then just put the email address.
And then this time, I am going to put update.
But if I click here, we can
see no matter where I click,
this is actually just becoming a form. There's
no way to change on this form. There's no way to
change what this CEO says first name, last name,
email address, there's no way to change on here,
what that looks like. So to actually change the
form, there's something else we have to do. So
what I'm going to do is going to set that I'm
going to go out of Elementor I'm gonna go to View
page. And then I'm gonna go to WP forms, WP forms
where you're going to make edits to the form. And
we have a newsletter signup form. And we have
a contact form where the newsletter signup form
was on the main page. Also, I think it's at the
bottom here to see here's the newsletter signup
form. And then here's the contact form.
So I'm going to go to edit form. Okay,
so here's how we can edit the form. So we have
the first name, last name, email address message,
what if we want something else so I can actually
add a different another thing to this form. So
I'm going to go to add fields. And you can see we
have a lot of different choices. What I'm going to
add is a drop down so I'm just going to drag it
in. And now if I click it says click to edit if
I click here, I can now change this so how did
you hear about us and you can say search engine
advertisement
word of mouth. And we can set this required
if we want. And see when we hit required,
I'll put that asterik. And you then you won't be
able to submit the form unless it's filled out.
But we will make this required. So we just added
that to the form and see how this has to as first
name and last name? Well, if I go here, I'm going
to go to simple. So now it's only gonna have one
field. So we basically can do first, middle
last, first, last, or simple, which is just,
it's just going to have one blank for the name. So
that's what we want. So we want the one blank for
the name. And and then we want the email address,
how did you hear about us and message and it's
set up. So when you click submit, it's going to
automatically submit the email to whatever email
address you have as your administrator email on
WordPress. So it's automatically gonna just send
an email right to your email address. And there's
a bunch of other things you can do on this day, a
bunch of different other types of fields, you
can use like these ones, I think you have to
get the paid version. But this is just going to be
just enough this, but just these fields are going
to be pretty good. So I'm going to save this.
And if I put x on here, and then I'm going to
go back to my site, and we go back to the contact
form. And now we can see this, so the name field,
and that just gives us one, one box here, I guess
it doesn't say name and there anymore. So that's,
that's what we probably want to change that but
we have email address, now we can choose from
this drop down box really quick, let's see
how we can change that to actually show that
that's the name field. So I'm gonna go to edit
again, the contact form, go to the name field.
And then under advanced, I can put what
the placeholder is. So placeholder is
what's going to show up in there until someone
types in something, so I'll just type in name,
and then default value will be so then this
placeholder is gonna be like the grayed out text,
a default value would be an actual entry
that would automatically be in there. So
I'm going to save that. And we will go back
to the page. And now Yeah, so I can click
here. And I can just select my name here, and
you can see it. So when nothing was in there,
we had the placeholder which says name here, the
fields required. And then, so I can type in that.
Hello, and then I'll just click
Submit, and it should submit that form.
And see when I submit it says, Thanks for
contacting us, we will be with you shortly. Well,
that's another thing that you set up in WP forms,
let me go back to the contact page like that. I've
got a contact form, edit form. And if I go to
Settings, and then confirmations, thanks for
contacting us, we'll be in touch with you shortly.
So this is where you would change what's going to
show on the page when someone fills out the form.
Now, if you go through and test out your form,
and it doesn't work, let me show you how you
can fix that. So we're gonna go go to settings,
notifications. And if you see right here, it says
the current from email address does not match
your website domain name, this can cause your
notification notification emails to be blocked or
marked as spam. So right now it's sending to the
end email, which is definitely what I want. But
it's coming from an email. But we don't want it to
come from edit admin email it's doing right here,
you may want to it says try using a form
address that matches your website domain.
And then it gives us a suggestion, which I'm
just going to use this Simon make it come come
from no reply@bow.net. And then we can also
change that. So this is going to be called
Tech tuber. And then we can even change the email
subject line that comes in. So I'll put new entry
tech tuba. And now I can just check all
these other things. And this looks good.
So I'm going to save this. Okay, now I'm going
to test out the form again. Now we could test
it on the page like we did before, but it can
also just test it here. But I can also test it
by just clicking this preview button here. And
now. It's the contact form preview so it's not
really on the contact page with exact same form.
And I just want to test to make sure it works.
Does my form work? Okay. You always want
to make sure it works before before you
launch your website because you want to make
Make sure that people sort of contact you,
it actually just does actually come in. And I
went to my email and actually had to go to my
spam folder. So I'm gonna go to my spam folder
here. And then you can see it came in. And
I'm going to do report not spam. So hopefully
next time, I won't go to my spam folder. Now,
we've already learned how to update a lot of parts
of our websites. But let's do a few more things.
You can see when I click reviews, if you look
at the URL here, that's not a really a good URL,
cat equals three, we want this to say, reviews
here. So and then if I click on actual article,
it just says P equals 39. That's not the type
of URL that we want. And it's not really search
engine optimized. So I'm gonna go back over to
my dashboard, then I'm gonna go to Settings,
and then go to permalinks. So this is where we
change what the link is going to look like. And
right now we have on plane, that's the default.
And that's basically the worst thing that you
don't you don't want plane. Personally, I think
the best thing is just to use post name. So this
is going to be a lot more readable URL. And so
it's not just going to be like P equals 123,
it's going to be the actual name of the post.
So I'm going to click save changes. And then
I'm just going to refresh here. And now if I go
to reviews, we can see category reviews. Well,
that's all I want go here, category gaming. If I
click on a actual article, you can see actually
the article now this is just some sample text here
for the article name. But if we go let's go to
the article that that we wrote here, they click
here, website offers free developer curriculum,
that looks pretty good, that looks a lot better.
But let me show you how you would if you didn't
like this URL, let me show you how you change that
I forgot to edit post here, I can actually edit
the post, but I can also edit the URL. So just
click right into the URL here. And website offers
free instead, website offers free drip developer
curriculum, I'm going to say Free Code Camp.
Okay, now update. And then
we will, I'll go to Preview
and preview a new tab. And now we can see. So we
don't really want the preview, we want the actual
one. So let me go to news. And this Free Code Camp
offers free developer curriculum. Great, that's
the exact type of URL we want. Now I want to talk
to you more about making your website responsive.
What I'm gonna do is go into I'm gonna
go actually back to the homepage here,
I just click this link here or the the the logo
to go back to the homepage, and I'm gonna go back
to edit with Elementor. Now we're going to talk
about how to make sure it looks good, whether
it's on a desktop, a tablet, or a mobile device.
If we come down here to the bottom left corner,
and it says responsive mode. If I click this,
now, we can see this new menu at the top here,
I'm gonna go back to full screen. And we
can see this is desktop mode, tablet mode,
or mobile. So I'm gonna click on mobile. Now
it's showing what this is going to look like
on mobile. And we can actually make changes
like so far, this looks pretty good. But we can
actually make changes to what it's going to look
like only on mobile. So I'm going to click here.
And this, I want this to be centered, but only on
mobile. So I'm going to click on style, and then
okay, and then content. And then
I'm gonna click the centered button.
And then you can see, see how there's this little
mobile icon. That's how we know it's only being
centered when it's on mobile. So I can click
update. Now, let me switch between. So on the
not mobile on desktop, we can see this is left
aligned. But if I switch back to mobile, we can
see that it's centered. So that makes it it's and
then we can also see we have this hamburger menu
here. That's going to look a lot better on mobile.
And so that's just a nice way to test what your
website is going to look on for different aspect
ratios and different types of devices. See, that
looks pretty good. And then you can always make
changes that are specific to one type of device
or aspect ratio, just how I showed you. Okay, we
go out of this. And now we're going to look at
how we can update this footer here. So everything
down here, we can't just we can't just edit with
elemental and excellent go back into Elementor
there's no way to see it. If I move my mouse
around here, nothing's really highlighting as the
different sections. So to modify the footer, we're
gonna have to go there's a few different ways to
get into the method where you modify the footer,
but I'm gonna go into customize. And then once I'm
in the Customize header builder is how you update
what the header is going to look like. So we have
the menu here, the Search button. So if I just
if we like this subscribe button, what that's
really not helpful here, because we already have
the surprise the subscribe form in another place,
so I can just remove that subscribe button. And
the same thing with the header, I'm gonna go
or the same thing with the footer, I'm gonna
go to footer builder, and the footer builder, we
can see there's three different sections of the
footer. So this top section with the menu that's
right here, the social icons right here, then we
have this HTML, that's basically this text right
here, this widget, which is this subscribe form,
and the copyright form at the bottom. So if I
click on any one of those things, you can see
it's going to change what's in the side menu. So
the footer menu, I'm going to keep that basically
the same for the social icons, this is where I
can update the links for the social icons, or just
take them away, like, we're probably not going to
want Facebook. But for YouTube, I can just type
in the YouTube URL, so ACBS, colon slash less
youtube.com/free code camp, and then or we can
update the Twitter URL. So https colon, slash
slash twitter.com/free. Code Camp. And then
we can also change what the icons is going to
look like. So basically, I want the the icon,
but let's say we want to add a new new thing.
So I can, basically we can, we can click any
of these. And just to add social icon, it's gonna
look like little phone here. But I can change the
icon. And there's a bunch of icons available.
So it can just kind of go through these pages,
or I can search the icon, I'm going to make it
this bacterium. So if I click on that bacterium,
now we have a, we should be able to
have a bacterium, a bacterium icon.
But I don't really want that. So they go out of
that. And I'm, basically we're just going to have
to hear Twitter and YouTube. And then I can also
change this right here. So instead of sign up
to receive email updates for US News and more,
as I say, sign up to receive news. This button
this little form here, you edit just what that WP
forms the same way we updated the contact form,
you can update this was just one little, this
really small form here. And but now we can also
update the copyright. So we can say cap rate, we
can say when it says cap rate, and these, these
brackets here, that's the cap rate sign, current
year, site title. Anytime there's the brackets
that we're doing something dynamic here, the site
title, and then powered by site title, or we can
put created by, you can see it's an update right
there. Okay, now, I'm just going to publish that.
Okay, great. So now we learn how to
update all the stuff in the footer.
And this is looking pretty good. I mean, it's
not like professionally designed or anything. But
we're learning we've learned how to update pretty
much everything in this blog. Now let's learn how
to make one more type of page. So we know how
to make the blog entries. And we know how to
edit the list of blog entries here. But there's
this other type the about. So this about page
is a page. And let's say you want another just
informational page, you don't want to be a blog,
you want to just be some sort of other piece
of information that we can put on our websites.
Let's say that you want to offer consulting
services, and you want to give people information
about how they can learn more about that. Well,
let me show you how you would do that. Let's
go back to our administrator page. And I'm
gonna go to where it says pages. So first,
I'll just click here we can see all the current
pages, we can see that we have the about contact
home. And then we have some pages that we're not
using. Like we're not using the podcast page. So
right now I'm just going to delete this I'm gonna
click that and then just click trash, or it could
just click trash actually selecting it so you
can do a bulk action. But let's create a new
page and then we'll add it to our top menu. So I'm
gonna go up to the top it says add new But first,
I'm just going to close that. And then we'll add
a new page. And I will just call it consulting.
And you can just call it whatever you want. And
now we're going to edit it basically very similar
to how you edit a blog post, I offer consulting
services, if you want to schedule a meeting,
click the link below. And
now I'm going to add a button
contact me. And then I can just do contact if I if
I just type start typing contact, it will, it will
do a search for the different pages we already
have. So I can make this Contact Me button,
go to the contact page. So you can obviously add
different images, you can design this how you
want, like, I could click this plus button, plus
thing, and then add a gallery, where we can just
choose a few different images for the gallery.
Actually, this one, I will choose the people.
So you can choose all these images for a
gallery and then do create new gallery.
And you can even adjust the order of the
images in the gallery. Okay, so now let's
just see what this looks like. So I can before
I can publish it, I can also change the URL.
Right now it's on auto draft I'm going to so you
can see it's eventually going to be consulting,
that's going to be the permalink which which
is what we want, you can change the URL if
you want. And I will just click publish. And then
just click Publish again. And now I can view the
page. And here's our page consulting. If I offer
consulting service, we have the contact me which
goes to the contact page, it but we can go back.
And this doesn't really look that good. But you
can kind of get the idea of where you can just add
different pictures, you can design it exactly how
you want. So let's see how to add the consulting
page to this top menu. Well, it's similar to when
we were adjusting what links are up here. And we
can do the same thing with our consulting page. So
I'm going to go back to WordPress dashboard. And
then I'm going to go to Appearance and Menus. And
now we can add a new section. So basically, I can
click here, where it says consulting. And so these
are all the things that aren't currently in the
menu. Well, I guess some of them are in the menu,
but I'll click consulting and do Add to Menu.
And then I can just reorder it, and put it right
before about. And then if we go to Save Menu, and
now I can open the page again. And we can see that
the consulting page. So we have the the main page
views gaming, and consulting. Okay, we learned
how to add a page. Now let's talk about search
engine optimization. Let's go back to our main,
our main dashboard. So we are going to install
a special plugin that's going to help our blog
and our pages show up better in search engines.
So I'm gonna go to plugins, and I'm going to go
to Add New. Now I'm just going to Search for one
called Yoast SEO, y o a s t SEO. Now this is one
of the most popular SEO plugins you can see has
5 million active installations. This is another
one popular one. That's All In One SEO. But we're
gonna go with Yoast SEO installous. And it's going
to help us better optimize our WordPress site. So
after it's installed, I can just click Activate.
So we can see that our SS your site is already
easier to find it for search engine. So it
automatically does does some things right away,
but we can configure to make it even better. So
so let's go down and there is this paid version.
But we're just going to go with the free version,
because you can get a lot just with
the free version. So we'll start start,
we're starting to SEO data optimization. And it's
analyzing the site that way we don't even have
that much on the site. So it can so it is good. So
it works. If you already have a bunch on the site,
it will analyze it. But if you have it and then
you create another bunch of a bunch of blog posts
after you've already installed then it will kind
of work with with your content as you create it.
So click Continue. And does your site represent
organization or a person I'll go with person.
Now let's keep going on this. And then
we can add information now you don't
have to put in all this information, but
it helps Let's optimize the metadata. So
now I'm just going to add the Twitter.
So how about twitter.com/beau Carnes?
And then save and continue, oh, it's
to be s colon slash slash, there we go.
Now, do we want to give them data from the
site? Well, I'm just gonna put no don't
track my site data. I'm glad that that's the
default. And we can sign up for a newsletter,
I'm not going to do that. So Save and Continue.
And now we can visit the SEO dashboard.
So it's going to detect prompted, and luckily, we
don't have any SEO problems. But let's go through.
And then we can choose what features we want to
want to use. So all these features basically apply
to when you're creating a blog entry. So a lot
of things like the SEO analysis, the readability
analysis, and a lot of this is going to appear
when you're actually creating a blog post. So
and these weren't for both new posts and posts you
already have. So let me show you how that works.
I'm gonna go to the posts, and then we'll go to
the website offers free developer curriculum.
And if we scroll down here, we can see
there's a new section here, Yoast SEO.
And then we have the focus key phrase, and
we click here, it's gonna show what that is.
So it says, you'll find a focus key phrase
input field for every page on your site,
you can enter the keyword or key phrase you like
you'd like the page to rank for in Google. And
then the Yoast SEO will read check on the pages
contents to see if search engines will recognize
that's what it's about. So let's let's see how
that works. So for this, we want to get the phrase
learn to code. So I'm just going to type in,
learn to code. And we'll get related key phrases.
Okay, and I'm going to approve
it for this application.
And now we can see our related key phrases. So
I typed in, learn to code, and it's showing all
these related ones. But now that we've put in
this key phrase, so really a key phrase would
be other phrases that kind of go along with
it. So this will show us the volume of like,
how many searches are happening for that key
phrase? So we can try to figure out which
key phrase should we optimize for which key
phrases should we put in our title? Should we
put in the body of our article? And then so
let's just keep going down here and look at
some of these other things. We can see the Google
preview, what it's going to look like and Google.
And we can see information from the page. And then
look at this the SEO analysis. So this is going to
give us some information that we can improve on.
Have you evenly distributed your focus key phrase
throughout the whole text? Well, no, because it
was just like a very quick article. And we want
to see at some so these are all suggestions and
outbound links, and internal links. Make sure
the key phrases in the SEO title, update the
meta description link. That's this description
here that we can we can update that description,
that text link, that text link contains 13 words,
it's recommended to be 300 words. So it's gonna
give us all these suggestions, it gives us things
that we're doing good. And we can go through and
this is gonna give us some information about how
to make our articles more SEO friendly. And then
we can there's a bunch of other things here. But
let's go to this next tab, readability. So this is
going to tell us how read a readable article is.
And for the most part, we have a lot of good
results. But that's just because an article is
pretty short. So if you have a longer article,
it will give you more suggestions for how to
improve the readability. And here is where you
can update the schema. Now it says right here,
this helps search engines understand your website
and your content. So this page default proposed
this is a blog post, we want to just keep it that
article type blog posts. So these are generally
going to be correct automatically. But if you want
to change like this, if this is the about page,
a fact page, these are those are going to be
more specific for those pages on the about page,
it's not going to know it's the about page unless
you specify. So that's basically how you can use
this SEO plugin to improve your SEO. Okay, and
that's about it. You now know enough to create
your own blog and to start customizing it to meet
your exact needs. We've reached the end of the
course. Good luck on making your own WordPress
website. And remember to use your code for good!